SO BUCKLE UP, TIME FOR OUR
BREAKING NEWS D.C. SWAMP OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
>> IT IS SIMPLE, THERE'S A
BATTLE BETWEEN THOSE CORE
PRINCIPLES OF THIS COUNTRY AND
THOSE WHO ONLY VALUE TO
POLITICAL VICTORIES.
NOW FROM DE LA ONE REPUBLICANS
HAVE TREATED THE CONFIRMATION
PROCESS OF JUDGE KAVANAUGH WITH
THE SERIOUSNESS IT DESERVES.
DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE NOT.
THEY'VE CREATED CHAOS AT JUDGE
KAVANAUGH'S HEARINGS,
INTERRUPTING AS YOU SAW DOZENS
OF TIMES.
THERE WERE CONSTANT OUTBURSTS
FROM LEFT-WING PROTESTERS,
DISRUPTING THE PROCEEDINGS AND
MUCH MORE.
NOW JUST DAYS AWAY FROM A FORMAL
VOTE AFTER ALL THE HEARINGS WERE
OVER AND SENATOR DIANNE
FEINSTEIN DROPS A BOMBSHELL.
AN ALLEGATION FROM A WOMAN
ACCUSING JUDGE KAVANAUGH OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT, GOING BACK 36
YEARS WHEN THEY WERE BOTH IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
NOW FEINSTEIN KNEW ABOUT THESE
ALLEGATIONS SINCE JULY AND SHE
KEPT THEM SECRET.
SHE KEPT THEM SECRET WHEN SHE
QUESTIONED KAVANAUGH PUBLICLY
AND FEINSTEIN USED AN ALLEGATION
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT TO DISRUPT
HIS NOMINATION.
THEY HAVE TAKEN THESE
ACCUSATIONS SERIOUSLY, AS THEY
SHOULD.
THERE IS STILL A CHANCE THAT WE
NOW HAVE NEWS THAT FORD MAY NOT
APPEAR.
APPARENTLY FORT HAS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE INDEPENDENT FEMALE
ATTORNEY HIRED TO QUESTION BOTH
FORD AND KAVANAUGH.
REPUBLICANS ARE CLEARLY TRYING
TO DO EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER
AS THEY HAVE BEEN DOING TO
ACCOMMODATE PROFESSOR FORD.
EITHER WAY, A VOTE ON KAVANAUGH
HAS BEEN SCHEDULED FOR THIS
FRIDAY.
JUDGE KAVANAUGH HAS BEEN BEGGING
FOR A CHANCE TO CLEAR HIS NAME
UNDER OATH SINCE THE CHARGES
FIRST BECAME PUBLIC.
HE HAS CATEGORICALLY DENIED
THESE ALLEGATIONS OVER AND OVER
AND VIRTUALLY NO EVIDENCE IS
BACKING UP PROFESSOR FORD'S
36-YEAR-OLD CLAIM.
THE FOUR WITNESSES PROFESSOR
FORD LISTED TO CORROBORATE HER
STORY, ALL OF THEM, DENIED WHAT
SHE IS ALLEGING, ALL FOUR.
NOW MANY ON THE LEFT ARE
DEMEANING THAT THE FBI
INVESTIGATE FORD'S ALLEGATIONS
THAT NO CONFIRMATION VOTE SHOULD
TAKE PLACE UNTIL THE FBI WEIGHS
IN.
REMEMBER, THEY KNEW THIS BACK IN
JULY.
TONIGHT THEY SHOULD TAKE ADVICE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M SAYING THIS,
OF CRAZY UNCLE JOE BIDEN.
SO WHAT HE SAID BACK IN 1991.
>> THE NEXT PERSON THAT REFERS
TO AN FBI REPORTER AS BEING
WORTH ANYTHING OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND ANYTHING.
FBI EXPLICITLY DOES NOT IN THIS
OR ANY OTHER CASE REACH A
CONCLUSION.
PERIOD.
>> Tucker: THAT DEMEANS THE
DEMOCRATS, DUE PROCESS AND
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE
LITERALLY MEAN NOTHING TO THEM.
ESPECIALLY DELAWARE
SENATOR CHRIS COATES.
HE ACTUALLY THINKS THAT JUDGE
KAVANAUGH HAS TO PROVE HIS
INNOCENCE, I'M NOT MAKING THIS
UP.
>> TO JUST DISENGAGE, IT IS
JUDGE KAVANAUGH WHO IS SEEKING A
LIFETIME APPOINTMENT TO THE
SUPREME COURT AND WHO I THINK
NOW BEARS THE BURDEN OF
DISPROVING THESE ALLEGATIONS
RATHER THAN DR. FORD AND
MR. RAMIREZ.
>> THAT'S SAD.
SENATOR, REMIND ME OF THIS NEXT
TIME YOU TALK TO HIM.
DEMOCRATS WANT A CHEAP POLITICAL
VICTORY AT ALL COSTS, EVEN IF
THAT MEANS THROWING INALIENABLE
RIGHTS RIGHT OUT THE WINDOW.
SMEARING, SLANDER, DISBURSEMENT.
>> THE SENATE SHOULD RELY ON TWO
CONFLICTING ACCOUNTS, AND WE ARE
OKAY WITH NOT KNOWING WE MIGHT
PUT SOMEONE THAT IS -- LIKE THAT
ON THE SENATE.
>> ANYONE WHO COMES FORWARD AT
THIS POINT AND IS PREPARED TO
TESTIFY IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE, THAT TAKES AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF COURAGE.
>> NOT ONLY DO WOMEN THAT DR.
DR. FORD BRIEFLY COMES FORWARD
AND SHOULD BE HEARD, THEY NEED
TO BE BELIEVED.
>> I HAVE TO SAY TO THE MEN OF
THIS COUNTRY, JUST SHUT UP AND
SET UP.
>> I BELIEVE DR. FORD, I BELIEVE
THE SURVIVOR HERE.
THERE IS EVERY REASON TO BELIEVE
HER.
SHE HAS COME FORWARD
COURAGEOUSLY AND BRAVELY.
>> I BELIEVE HER AND -- I DON'T
THINK SHE SHOULD BE BULLIED INTO
THE SCENARIO WHERE IT'S HE SAID,
SHE SAID IT, IT'S A SHAM
HEARING.
I DON'T THINK SHE SHOULD
PARTICIPATE IN IT.
>> I BELIEVE PROFESSOR FORD, I
THINK SHE'S CREDIBLE AND I THINK
WHEN THE INVESTIGATION IS
FINISHED, AND WHEN SHE
TESTIFIES, AND WHEN JUDGE
KAVANAUGH TESTIFIES, I THINK A
MAJORITY OF SENATORS WILL FIND
>> Tucker: >> Sean: MEN
>> Tucker: >> Sean: MES
>> Tucker: >> Sean: MEU
>> Tucker: >> Sean: MET
HER CREDIBLE.
>> Tucker: >> Sean: ME?
I BELIEVE THAT MEANS NO DUE
PROCESS OR PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
JUDGE KAVANAUGH IS ALSO FACING
AN ADDITIONAL OBLIGATION, A
TOTALLY UNCORROBORATED CLAIM
FROM A WOMAN NAMED DEBORAH
RAMIREZ.
SHE TOLD THE NEW YORK CURE IN
THE 1980s, 34 YEARS AGO
KAVANAUGH EXPOSED HIMSELF AT A
DRUNKEN COLLEGE PARTY.
AND GET THIS, RAMIREZ HERSELF
ISN'T EVEN TOTALLY SURE THAT
KAVANAUGH WAS A PERPETRATOR.
SHE SAID SHE BECAME "QUICKLY
INEBRIATED" AT THE PARTY.
SHE TOLD THE NEW YORKER, SHE WAS
A "FOGGY AND SLURRING HER
WORDS."
SHE EVEN ACKNOWLEDGES SHE HAS
SIGNIFICANT MEMORY GAPS FROM
THAT EVENING.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" -- EVEN
ASKING IF SHE REMEMBERED THE
INCIDENT.
AND, WITH CONFIDENCE, IF THE
INCIDENT EVER OCCURRED WE WOULD
HAVE SEEN OR HEARD ABOUT IT, AND
WE HAVE NOT.
THE BEHAVIOR SHE DESCRIBES WOULD
BE COMPLETELY OUT OF CHARACTER
FOR BRETT.
SHE ALSO THE NEW YORKER
INTERVIEWED RAMIREZ'S BEST
FRIEND AT THE TIME OF THE
INCIDENT, AND SHE ALSO IS
DENYING ANY KNOWLEDGE OF THE
CLAIMS.
I WAS NEVER TOLD THIS STORY BY
HER OR ANYONE ELSE.
IT NEVER CAME UP, I DIDN'T SEE
IT, AND "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
COULDN'T CORROBORATE THE STORY
IN ANY WAY.
THEY REFUSED TO PUBLISHED THE
CLAIMS AS PART OF HER REPORTING
AND SAID SHE SPENT WEEKS FINDING
ONE PERSON TO CORROBORATE IT.
CHAIRMAN GRASSLEY WILL NOT BE
CALLING MR. RAMIREZ TO TESTIFY.
STILL DESPITE THE LACK OF
EVIDENCE, THE LEFT OF COURSE
RUSHING TO JUDGMENT AS THEY HAVE
IN SO MANY PRIOR OCCASIONS,
SMEARING JUDGE KAVANAUGH, NOT
EVEN WANTING TO HEAR HIS SIDE OF
IT.
AND RUSHING TO JUDGMENT AND
SAYING, I BELIEVE ONE PERSON.
THIS IS DANGEROUS FOR ANYONE IN
SOCIETY, WE SHOULD ALL BELIEVE
IT WOULD BE POLITICAL.
WE SHOULD BELIEVE IN THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE BUT
MANY DON'T.
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS IS A MONUMENTAL DEFINING
MOMENT THIS WEEK WHEN YOU HAVE
SOMEONE LIKE HIM GOING TO PRISON
AND IN THE SAME BREATH,
KAVANAUGH POSSIBLY GOING TO THE
HIGHEST COURT IN THE LAND.
>> WE WANT AMERICA TO BELIEVE
THAT THE ONLY THING HE DID UNTIL
WELL INTO HIS COLLEGE YEARS WAS
EFFECTIVELY KISS OR WRENCH KISS
A WOMAN.
IS THAT WHAT HE WANTS AMERICA TO
BELIEVE?
>> AND TO BE HONEST THAT'S VERY
MUCH A WHITE MALE REPUBLICAN
DEFENSE.
>> IF THEY GO THROUGH A SENATE
HEARING, AND IT BECOMES A SEAT,
CIRCUS, THEY PUSH IT THROUGH AND
IT PASSES, THERE WILL BE AS WE
SAID LAST WEEK AN ASTERISK THAT
IS THERE AS LONG AS HE'S THERE.
>> SO IF NANCY PELOSI,
CONGRESSWOMAN MAXINE WATERS, AND
MICHAEL AVENATTI ALL GOING ON
TV, AND ACTUALLY THREATENING TO
EXPOSE NOW A GANG RATE SCANDAL
ABOUT JUDGE KAVANAUGH, E IS THE
LEAD GUEST ON FAKE NEWS CNN.
THEY LOVE MICHAEL AVENATTI.
SO JUST TO RECAP, WE HAVE HEARD
FROM DEMOCRATS RUSHING TO
JUDGMENT.
WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA RUSHING TO
JUDGMENT.
WE'VE HEARD FROM FUTURE DINNER
MIKE DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE MICHAEL AVENATTI, AND,
THE LESS ANGRY MOB IS JOINING
THE STOP CAVANAUGH MOVEMENT.
THE LAST NIGHT, AT THE FAR LEFT
ACTIVISTS RAN INTO SENATOR TED
CRUZ AND HIS WIFE WHO WAS GOING
OUT TO A RESTAURANT IN THE SWAMP
WHILE MINDLESSLY CHANTING WE
BELIEVE SURVIVORS.
WATCH THIS.
[CHANTING]
WE BELIEVE SURVIVORS!
>> Sean: IN THE LAST YEAR, WE
PLAYED IT HERE WE'VE HEARD
CONGRESSWOMAN MAXINE WATERS, AND
EVEN BARACK OBAMA GET INTO THEIR
FACE.
FOLLOW THEM INTO GROCERY STORES.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING AND
WITNESSING HERE IS A KEY PART
OF, WHAT IS THE DEMOCRATIC
PLAYBOOK?
WE SEEN THESE CONFRONTATIONS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
SECRETARY KIRSTJEN NIELSEN, PAM
BONDI, MOB MENTALITY, THESE
TACTICS HAVE LEFT ARE NOW IN
FULL GEAR 42 DAYS OUT OF AN
ELECTION.
AND SENATOR TED CRUZ 'OPPONENT
WAS GIVEN A STATEMENT OVER HIS
DUI WHERE HE LITERALLY LEFT THE
SCENE OF A DUI ACCIDENT, TWO
TIMES THE LEGAL LIMIT, BUT
DENIED THAT EVER HAPPENED.
IF THE LEFT TRULY BELIEVE
SURVIVORS, THEY MIGHT WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE DEPUTY CHAIR OF
THEIR OWN PARTY, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, KEITH ELLISON.
HIS EX-GIRLFRIEND HAS ACCUSED
HIM OF REPEATED PHYSICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND EMOTIONAL
ABUSE, DATING BACK TO JUST A
SHORT TIME AGO.
HE'S NOW RUNNING TO BE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE STATE OF
MINNESOTA.
HE'S THE NUMBER TWO GUY AT THE
DNC AND AT A DEBATE LAST WEEK,
HERE'S WHAT HE HAD TO SAY ABOUT
THESE RECENT CLAIMS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT NO ONE
ELSE WILL STEP FORWARD?
>> IN THIS POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
SOMEBODY MIGHT COOK UP BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NOBODY THAT I'M AWARE
OF WHO HAS ANY SORT OF -- WHO IS
THREATENING OR SUGGESTING ARE
EVER MADE A PRIOR ACCUSATION.
>> Sean: SO MANY OF THESE
DEMOCRATS I WON'T GIVE DUE
PROCESS TO JUDGE KAVANAUGH, THEY
HAVEN'T UTTERED A WORD ABOUT
THEIR NUMBER TWO FOR THEIR
PARTY.
THEY MAY LEARN MORE.
ELLISON HAS YET TO FACE AN ANGRY
MOB CHANTING, WE BELIEVE
SURVIVORS.
THEY HAVE YET TO BE CONVICTED ON
TV, AND HE IS ACCUSED OF HAVING
FOR CAMPAIGN FUNDS.
HE'S BEEN ACCUSED OF RATE AND
HERE'S WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY
EARLIER TODAY ON A RADIO PROGRA
PROGRAM.
AND THE STIPULATION            D
AND THE STIPULATION            P
AND THE STIPULATION            S
AND THE STIPULATION            T
AND THE STIPULATION            O
AND THE STIPULATION            N
AND THE STIPULATION            F
AND THE STIPULATION            O
AND THE STIPULATION            M
AND THE STIPULATION            A
AND THE STIPULATION            D
AND THE STIPULATION            N
I SAID PLEASE READ THIS ACCOUNT
AND THE STIPULATION            T
ONE OF THEM WOULD READ IT?
>> THEY HAVE SO MUCH MORE IN
THIS DOUBLE STANDARD ALL
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
EDITS AT THE REST OF THE MEDIA
WON'T REPORT ON THIS.
TODAY AND TOMORROW, , AND THURSA
WE WILL BE IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
TODAY AND TOMORROW, , AND THURSY
FOR THE UPCOMING HEARING.
AND IF PROFESSOR FORD DECIDES TO
TELL HER STORY, WE WILL LISTEN.
SO WHILE ALL OF THIS IS GOING O
ON, THE PRESIDENT, WHO IS IN
NEW YORK AT THE TIME AND
LITERALLY PUSHING HIS AMERICA
FIRST AGENDA MOVING FORWARD WITH
HISTORIC SUCCESS, AND TODAY AT
THE U.N., HE STOOD UP SOLIDLY
FOR AMERICA FIRST.
IN FRONT OF THE WORLD STAGE.
I THINK ONE OF HIS BEST SPEECHES
TO DATE, TAKE A LISTEN.
IT'S ALMOST ANY ADMINISTRATION
IN THE HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
AMERICA IS SO TRUE.
I DIDN'T EXPECT THAT REACTION
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
AMERICA'S ECONOMY IS BOOMING
LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
THE STOCK MARKET IS AT AN
ALL-TIME HIGH IN HISTORY AND
JOBLESS CLAIMS ARE AT A 50 YEAR
LOW.
>> Sean: THAT'S A GREAT
SUCCESS FOR THE FORGOTTEN MEN
AND WOMEN THAT CAME OUT TO VOTE
IN 2016.
ARE YOU GOING TO GO OUT AND VOTE
AND KEEP THE REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS SO THE AGENDA AND
SUCCESS CAN CONTINUE?
AND, WE DO HAVE RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT.
HISPANIC AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS AND 65 YEAR LOW
FOR WOMEN IN THE WORKFORCE IN
AMERICA.
FOR A MILLION FEWER PEOPLE ON
FOOD STAMPS, 4 MILLION MORE
AMERICANS WORKING, BREAKING
RECORDS IN THE STOCK MARKET,
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE HITTING AN
18 YEAR HIGH, AND IT NOW, A BLUE
WAVE.
GUESS WHAT, TONIGHT IT MAY NOT
BE SO CERTAIN IS THAT MEDIA HAS
BEEN PEDDLING TO EVERYBODY.
REPUBLICAN FAVORABILITY OUT
TODAY HAS NOW HIT A SEVEN YEAR
HIGH.
AMERICANS LITERALLY SPENT MORE
ON TAXES IN THE YEARS 2013
THROUGH 2016 THAN THEY DID ON
FOOD AND CLOTHING.
BY THE WAY, THE DEMOCRATS WANT
THEIR CRIMES BACK.
IT'S NO SECRET OF THE
PRESIDENT'S SUCCESS.
HE DOESN'T GO ON APOLOGY TOUR
IS, HE PUTS AMERICA FIRST AND IT
WORKS.
>> President Trump: AMERICA
WILL ALWAYS CHOOSE INDEPENDENCE
AND COOPERATION OVER GLOBAL
GOVERNMENTS, CONTROL AND
DOMINATION.
I ENCOURAGE EVERY DENOMINATION
IN THIS ROOM TO PURSUE ITS OWN
CUSTOMS AND TRADITIONS.
THE UNITED STATES WILL NOT TELL
YOU HOW TO LIVE OR WORK OR
WORSHIP.
WE ONLY ASK THAT YOU HONOR OUR
SOVEREIGNTY IN RETURN.
WE DO NOT ALLOW OUR CITIZENS TO
BE VICTIMIZED, OUR WORKERS TO BE
CHEATED AND OUR WEALTH TO BE
PLUNDERED OR TRANSFERRED.
AMERICA WILL NEVER APOLOGIZE FOR
PROTECTING ITS CITIZENS AND WE
WILL NEVER SURRENDER AMERICA'S
SOVEREIGNTY TO AN UNELECTED,
UNACCOUNTABLE, GLOBAL
BUREAUCRACY.
AMERICA IS GOVERNED BY AMERICAN
AMERICANS.
AND WE REJECT THE IDEOLOGY OF
GLOBALISM AND EMBRACE THE
DOCTRINE OF PATRIOTISM.
>> AND 42 DAYS YOU GET TO DECIDE
IF THIS CONTINUES.
THE CLOIS TO MAKE A CHOICE IS
NOT CLEAR FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IT'S VERSUS THE PARTY FIRST.
THEY FORCE THE PRINCIPALS, LAW
AND ORDER.
THAT IS VERSUS THE PARTY OF
ECONOMIC GROWTH, LESS BURDENS OF
REGULATIONS, LOWER TAXES, ENERGY
AND, 42 DAYS, THEIR LIFE IS